[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons aborder un sujet passionnant
c'est celui de la république la
république
une histoire elle a une réalité et on
entend beaucoup aussi aujourd'hui parler
de république on parle d'ordre public en
parle de valeurs républicaines mais
qu'est ce que c'est cette république est
ce que cette république justement qu'est
une histoire est aussi adapté à la
société de ce temps c'est ce dont nous
allons parler pendant cette émission
avec marie le bec
bonjour vous êtes député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines vous êtes
la première vice-présidente du groupe
lrm à l'assemblée l'un florence mercadé
choqué bonjour moselle jean patrice
avocate au barreau de versailles est
alors en vision nous sommes avec didier
fischer bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
maire de coignières et mais vous êtes
aussi historien et vous venez de publier
une biographie qui s'appelle léon blum
dont qui consacrait à léon blum assas ya
pas de doute pas de doute
éditions ellipses et justement c'est
passionnant parce que dans ce livre on
va en reparler vous parlais justement
des valeurs républicaines de léon blum
et puis nous sommes aussi avec stéphane
minson bonjour longeau patrice bonjour à
tous
professeur de droit de l'université de
versailles saint quentin vous êtes
ancien doyen de cette université
alors on va parler de la république
peut-être avant marie de pecs puisque
vous êtes ici
il ya cette polyclinique peut-être cette
affaire d'état je ne sais pas comment il
faut qualifier sur l'article 24 de la
loi sur la sécurité globale
on rappelle en gros c'est un art et
qu'est censé protéger les policiers
contre la diffusion d'image dans la
presse ou sur les réseaux sociaux et le
vote de cet de cet article est tombé au
moment où il ya eu une bavure policière
dans le 17e arrondissement et on se dit
justement bas s'il n'y avait pas eu d'
image peut-être qu'on ne laisserai pas
comment ça se passe l'article est votée
alors l'article voté en première lecture
à l'assemblée nationale
et maintenant on est dans le cadre de la
navette parlementaire c'est-à-dire que
le texte va partir au sénat où il va
être débattue enrichi et puis on verra
soit les deux chambres se mettre
d'accord sur une rédaction soit le texte
revient à à l'assemblée nationale et
qu'est ce que vous pensez enfin de cette
polémique évidemment le midi donateurs
gérald à main et est au premier plan
était sous le feu des critiques
évidemment sur l'article 24 sur
l'agression dont a été victime
michel est claire je crois que ces deux
sujets qui sont très différent puisque
l'article 24 essais notamment le sens
des débats parlementaires et c'est pour
ça que c'est aussi une discussion
intéressante a été largement enrichie
pour dire qu'il faut que quand on
utilise l'article 24
quand on cherche à le faire appliquer
s'il devait être adopté définitivement
et ça ne nuit pas à la liberté
d'informer au droit de la presse et ça
doit être avec l'intention manifeste de
nuire aux forces de l'ordre
or là on voit bien que la diffusion des
images dans le cadre de la sphère michel
est claire elle ne nuit pas aux
policiers elle permet d'informer elles
permettent d'alerter sur une bavure une
dérive qui doit être fermement
sanctionnés
je crois que ce sont deux affaires
totalement différente en revanche moi je
suis pour cet article 24
peut-être qu'il doit être enrichi et
amélioré mais je crois que ces deux sens
aussi du travail parlementaire
pour la simple et bonne raison que moi
je viens d'un département où il y a et
deux
représentant de la police mais aussi un
enseignant qui ont été assassinés et
notamment pour lesquelles on a diffusé
des images d'eux et on a donné des
informations personnelles sur sur leur
vie privée permettant à la fois de les
identifier et de les retrouver
et c'est avec avec cet article 24 c'est
ce contre quoi nous essayons de lutter
évident à penser on en avait parlé déjà
ici mais c'est l'ambiguïté de cette
intention de nuire qui peut qui peut
poser problème
moi je fais confiance dans la justice de
notre pays pour justement être en
capacité d'établir je crois que c'est
très important de donner au juge
mais vous voyez bien que c'est très
différent quand vous diffuser une vidéo
comme ça a été fait pour la faire à
michel éclair en alertant sur des
comportements et quand vous diffuser une
vidéo en indiquant où vont les enfants
de ce policier à l'école à quelle heure
l'enseignant quitte les courts
par quel chemin il rentre chez lui vous
voyez qu'il ya une différence très nette
de ce qu'ils aient l'intention de nuire
ceux là des articles dans le code pénal
donc je pense par 24 sur ce terrain-là
apporte quoi que ce soit puisque c'est
déjà réprimé par le code
mais ne pensez vous pas que sur
l'intention manifeste de nuire si par
exemple une la personne qui filme mais
au lieu de films et de chez elles
étaient dans la rue en train de filmer
vous pourriez avoir un policier qui
disent je vous donne injonction
d'arrêter de file de films et je vous
donne là un et vous avez une intention
manifeste de nuire puisque vous
continuer à filmer et hop garde à vue
même si derrière la garde à vue sera
levé puisqu'il n'y aura rien à reprocher
mais vous aurez couper le film à ce
moment là et la personne sera en garde à
vue pendant la fin de toutes ces
problématiques dans ce soit l'agression
michel ziegler où que ce soit dans des
manifestations ou autre et ça c'est la
véritable crainte aussi que l'on peut
avoir par rapport à cet article c'est
pour ça qu'on a apporté effectivement
toutes les précisions sur en indiquant
que ça ne devait pas entraver la liberté
d'information où est la liberté de la
presse je crois que c'était une pression
qui étaient importantes et qui était
attendu dans le cadre du
une cadre du débat et puis il ya eu
effectivement un peu cette discussion
autour de la diffusion en direct mais il
faut quand même noter que dans ce texte
de loi sur la sécurité globale
on a aussi le renforcement de
l'utilisation des caméras piétons qui
sont portés sur les policiers donc on
considère que l'image le simple fait de
filmer n'est pas une intention de nuire
il faut plutôt considérer le fait de
dire c'est qu'est-ce que vous allez
mettre comme message avec avec 7 avec
cette vidéo
et puis au demeurant encore une fois
j'entends que effectivement certains
estiment qu' il peut y avoir
ça peut en prendre à la liberté de la
presse mais vous savez bien comme moi
que dans une manifestation dans le cadre
d'une manifestation
s'il y a des scènes violentes s'il ya
des débordements la police est plutôt
occupé à contenir ses débordements car
on peut s'estimer aujourd'hui quasiment
tout le monde va en manifestation avec
des caméras que soient les forces de
l'ordre d'ailleurs c'est une bonne chose
ou que ce soit les manifestants donc je
crois que il ne faut pas estimé qu on ne
pourra plus informés mais vraiment se
dire que c'est dans un cadre très
restreint qui permet de protéger
vous avez dit on ne peut pas retirer
enfin il ya déjà des articles qui
permettent de sanctionner mais ce n'est
pas exact puisque on ne peut pas pardon
retirer certaines informations qui ne
sont pas des appels à la violence mais
qui sont des informations qui relèvent
de votre vie privée et qui pourraient
lui mais attention en vous remettant
geely a une intention de nuire manifeste
bat on peut aller sur le terrain
attention le mur est-ce que sur ce sujet
didier fischer stéphane montceau voulait
intervenir ou non moi je
florence le noter et puis je rejoins
d'ailleurs assez globalement ce que dit
ce que précise marie le mec c'est à dire
que il ya d'un côté c'est vrai qu'on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas laisser se
propager des des images des informations
qui concernent les membres des forces de
l'ordre dans leur vie privée c'est vrai
que dans les yvelines on est on est bien
placé pour pour savoir ce à quoi ça a pu
aboutir
et il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
également protégés et les forces de
l'ordre en intervention lorsqu elle
respecte le droit et c'est le cas dans
dans 99 9% des hypothèses de l'autre
côté je moi j'ai plutôt confiance dans
la jurisprudence c'est-à-dire que la
liberté d'informer la libre
communication des idées et des opinions
la liberté d'expression elle est et quoi
qu'on en dise et quoi qu'on en pense
très fortement ancrée dans notre système
juridique donc je pense que devant un
juge
c'est la liberté d'information la
liberté d'expression la liberté voire
même le devoir de dénoncer d'éventuelles
violences d'éventuelles exactions qui
qui qui l'emportera mais je je je
n'oublie pas malgré tout que il est à un
moment un autre indispensable de donner
un certain nombre de garanties aux
forces de l'ordre d'intervention très
bien non mais ce qui est noté ce qui
d'ailleurs est diffusée sur les
informations en tout cas ce matin c'est
que vous avez l'article 25 de l'autre
projet de loi qui est en cours d'étude
est issu renforcement des valeurs public
et cet article 25 a été fait justement
pour protéger en réalité cet article
découle de l'assassinât de ce professeur
et cet article 25 correspond à cet
article 24 sauf que l'article 24 va
toucher à la loi sur la presse et
l'article 25 va toucher au code pénal
mais il recouvre les mêmes
les mêmes domaines donc pourquoi ne pas
abandonner cet article 24 et laisser
l'article 25 qui arrive maghrib et déjà
à noter c'est une proposition doit louer
l'article 24 sur la sécurité globale
donc à l'initiative des parlementaires
la loi séparatisme ou valeurs
républicaines est un projet de loi à
l'initiative du gouvernement
les temps de débats ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes et vous avez raison
peut-être que l'article 25 rendra
caduque de fait l'article 24 et dans ce
cas on peut le supprimer dans le cadre
de la discussion parlementaire je crois
que ce qui est important c'est d'une de
s'accorder le temps du débat et moi je
trouve ça très intéressant que l'on
puisse confronter nos opinions que l'on
puisse enrichir l'article ci on souhaite
le garder qu'on puisse le supprimer si
cela est nécessaire mais je crois d'une
qu'il faut pas avoir peur de ce débat il
me paraît ça me parait est en débat
légitime
quelle utilisation fait des images
surtout quelle utilisation en fait sur
les réseaux sociaux
ce ne sont pas des zones de non-droit
sur lesquels on peut faire ce qu'on veut
et n'importe quoi et puis effectivement
je crois que peut-être que l'article 25
finalement se prêtera mieux et une une
acception plus large de son utilisation
et que l'article 24 de fès 1 suprême il
n'y a pas de sujet en ce cas dans la
discussion de parlementaires de retirer
c'est aussi comme ça qu'on construit la
loi il ya une navette le 10e et y
appuierait priem aussi le conseil
constitutionnel qui est tout à fait tu
peux aussi alors on voit passer
justement à la république est justement
la république c'est quoi c'est le
premier temps la démission alors quand
on assiste à une déclaration du
président de la république
ça se termine toujours par vive l'europe
vive la france vive la république c'est
le dernier mot stéphane manceau on sait
depuis quand est-ce que moi j me semble
que c'est depuis de gaulle mais
peut-être que je me trompe qu'on dit jeu
là je voyais je me retournerais vers
didier mais ce rien en vous disant qu
assez logiquement
vous me semblez être dans le juste parce
qu'au fond la retransmission télévisée
d'allocations présidentielle avant de
gaulle je crois qu'il y en a eu assez
peu et il me semble que c'est assez
assez gaullien 7,7 cette proclamation
qui me semble qu'il se fait toutefois
dans un ordre inversé de celui que vous
que vous évoquiez la force à voile à des
défis soeur je rejoins je rejoins
stéphane minson sur le sujet je pense
qu'effectivement le c'est à partir du
début de la vème république et c'est
effectivement de gaulle en tous les cas
c'est ce qui ressort des archives que
j'ai pu en effet consulter ces dernières
années c'est en effet plutôt de gaulle
qui je dirais conclu la plupart de ses
discours la plupart un pas tous quand
même
par exemple celui sur la tentative de
putsch il ne termine pas sûr vive la
république vive la france
mais la plupart de ses discours il est
conclu de cette façon là cependant quand
on cherche on recherche un peu les peu
plus précisément les choses on voit que
je dirais cette formule est utilisée
aussi sous la troisième république sous
la quatrième république par des
parlementaires par exemple par le
président de l'assemblée constituante
par exemple en 1 en avril 1946 vincent
auriol notamment vincent auriol
utilisent cette formule mais dans le
sens inverse vive la france vive la
république quand il présente la
constitution donc de la quatrième
république qui d'ailleurs n'a pas été
adopté à ce moment là puisque
votes au mois de mai fait que le texte
est rejeté
mais voilà donc probablement c'est en
effet à partir de de gaulle un formule
gaullienne comme le disait stéphane
pensons que l'habitude est prise en tous
les cas à ce moment là alors je vous
posais une question si grave qu'on sait
pas vous marie le bac jusqu'à présent en
f1 il semblait pas plus faire de doute
que la république était une valeur
incontesté et incontestable même depuis
que la république a pris le pas sur la
monarchie en tout cas et on a
l'impression aujourd'hui que la
république if d'idées même de république
est fragilisée est ce que c'est votre
votre sentiment aussi est ce qu'il faut
le réaffirmer vous allez le faire
d'ailleurs dans le projet de loi dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
bientôt tout à fait je pense que l'idée
peut-être et challenge et parce que ça
nécessite aussi je crois
une forme d'adaptation est ce qu'on
attend de la république au 21e siècle ce
n'est certainement pas la même chose que
ce qu'on attendait sous la troisième
république sous la quatrième république
et au début de la cinquième d'ailleurs
on voit certains responsables politiques
qui appellent c'est pas du tout mon cas
ni les valeurs que je partage mes à une
sixième république qui est justement
peut-être donnerait d'autres
représentations d'autres modes
d'expression aux citoyens d'autres
façons de participer à la vie politique
mais ça c'est l'organisation et le
fonctionnement de notre système
politique
mais au-delà de ça je crois que c'est
une communauté de valeurs et nous on a
trois grands principes fondateurs que
sont liberté égalité fraternité et pour
lequel je crois que c'est le christ de
la réponse est la vraie vie ce but mais
qui nous donne un peu la communauté de
destin à laquelle on appartient et qui
je crois nécessite que du coup ils
soient réaffirmées ils soient défendus
elle soit collectivement défendu au delà
bien sûr des différences que nous
pouvons partager des différences de
valeurs des différences de conception de
la vie politique et en tant que
responsable politique
j'aimerais que nous ayons et ce sera
intéressant dans le cadre des débats sur
la loi sur les valeurs républicaines que
nous soyons en capacité justement de
réaffirmer ce à quoi que collectivement
nous de nous et qui fait que nous in
fine et forme une nation qui partageant
une communauté de valeurs alors dit
fisher et stéphane et florence
d'ailleurs souvent dans les principes de
la république et le bec avez raison de
rappeler le triptyque liberté égalité
fraternité mais au parle du gouvernement
par le peuple au parle de la recherche
de l'intérêt collectif
quelle est la différence quelle
différence ont fait entre la république
et la démocratie
c'est une bonne question je pense que
stéphane pourra peut-être répondre plus
facilement que moi mais déjà déjà en
france qu'il faut remarquer à travers
l'histoire en effet de la république
c'est que la république s'est construite
contre la monarchie contre le despotisme
et donc quelque part en effet république
et démocratie en france sont liés
et ça c'est un point je crois qu'il faut
quand même souligner mais peut-être que
stéphane pourrait préciser
peut-être les les différentes
définitions on pourrait en effet donner
de la république la démocratie ni mais
oui parce qu'il peut il peut y avoir en
effet des démocratie monarchique coop
comme comme en angleterre en espagne et
céramique ne sont pas les république ne
sont pas forcément démocratique et
démocratie peuvent être aussi des
monarchies on le voit bien effectivement
en europe par exemple on le on le
constate donc il ya bien il y à il ya en
effet des différences bien sûr mais oui
récuper attendant oui pardon pardon
patrice oui c'était pour répondre à
votre à votre question
certes il ya à l'origine y en ait fait
une distinction une distinction
historique et théorique c'est à dire que
république didier fischer le précisait
c'est en référence à l'antiquité romaine
c'est à dire lorsque la un certain
système politique succède à la monarchie
c'est ce qui s'est passé ces sonos est à
rome
et puis c'est ce qui se passe ensuite en
1789 et c'est pour ça qu'on fait
référence à l'antiquité romaine et et
puis république devient aussi
progressivement à partir de du
développement de ddd des idées
humanistes à partir de la renaissance à
bien le gouvernement une forme de
gouvernement idéal ça le bon
gouvernement ce que pierre rosanvallon
appelle le bon gouvernement
et c'est pour cela que ce concept de
république
il est repris y compris par des systèmes
politiques qui ne sont absolument pas
démocratique
venise florence ont été des républiques
qui n'étaient pas des républiques
démocratiques qui était plutôt de forme
aristocratique d'ailleurs en 1789 91
il n'est pas question
de considérer alors la république est
proclamée en 92 mais elle et elle est
tout de même dans tous les esprits des
des 90 91 il n'est pas question de
consacrer une forme démocratique et on
entend par démocratie à l'époque une
forme de démocratie directe bon de
l'autre côté la démocratie c'est alors
que vous citiez gouvernement du peuple
par le peuple pour le peuple ça c'est la
formule de lincoln semble-t-il mais qui
qui relève du slogan moi moi je préfère
poser que la démocratie c'est deux
choses c'est d'une part la possibilité
d'être alternativement gouvernants et
gouvernés et puis d'autre part c'est la
possibilité de prendre part à une
délibération de délibéré la loi de
délibéré la règle c'est à dire de
prendre part à un débat qui est
susceptible de déboucher sur une une
solution alors consensuelle ou non mais
enfin sur une solution acceptable par
tous mais didier a raison en soulignant
qu' historiquement depuis disons depuis
la 2ème république en france depuis les
années 1800 48
on pose est évidemment que république et
démocratie en france sont totalement
indissociables il ya encore dans les
régimes contemporain des républiques
il ya eu les républiques populaires qui
n'était pas franchement démocratique
les républiques islamiques qui le sont
pas franchement toujours en france en
tout cas les deux sons sont sont
ontologiquement liées au baril le bec
alors l'origine historique de la
république c'est plutôt à gauche vous
êtes et de droite et de gauche il ya
plus de hofu il n'y a plus de
contestations partisane de la république
aujourd'hui on a autant républicains
quand tu es de gauche que de droite que
l assemblée par exemple voyez les mêmes
le bleu le réseau national ne conteste
plus la république
oui bah non mais je le souhaite et
j'espère
les spurs et c'est quand même un système
dans lequel je pense moi je crois que
cette notion de débat qui était évoqué
leur suppression est très très
intéressante parce qu'en fait finalement
c'est à la fois dire être en capacité
d'agir pour l'intérêt général qui n'est
pas la somme des intérêts particuliers
ce que parfois on oublie effectivement
le la capacité de dire on accepte le
débat et on accepte la divergence
d'opinion et je crois pas qu'il y ait
effectivement de droite ou de gauche
en tout cas sûre aujourd'hui la la la la
république et c'est heureux il ya
peut-être plus de challenge sur
l'acceptation du fait de dire l'autre
n'est pas d'accord avec moi mais je
respecte pour autant ses idées et je
crois que ce sera typiquement dans le
projet de loi dont tu parlais à
l'instant valeurs républicaines aussi
peut-être quelque chose qu'il faudra
réaffirmer puisque on parlait des
manifestations particulièrement
violentes
ce week-end on le voit aussi parfois
dans le monde politique des très fortes
tensions dans la capacité à accepter que
l'autre est un avis qui soit divergents
du sien auteurs et justement si je peux
enfin une question plus personnelle
vous êtes très jeune député au fond et
vous votre engagement politique
justement c'est qu'elle était le
fondement de cet engagement pourquoi
pourquoi vous avez aux murs vides de
faire de la politique de vous lancer
dans la vie politique
moi perso titre personnel je suis
quelqu'un naturellement très engagé
j'aime convaincre gm débattre j'aime
discuter j'aime entraîner aussi les
autres avec moi mais si vous voulez que
je vous dise l'acte fondateur et
paradoxalement c'est quelqu'un qui est
un petit peu disparu de la vie politique
mais à 14 ans mes parents m'ont amené
écouter justement christian blanc
dans un meeting politique à la mutualité
je sais pas pourquoi il avait choisi
cette personnalité je ne sais pas
comment nous sommes nous arrivés là mais
tu rembourses et pdg d'air france il
avait été à l'époque je crois qu'ils
avaient été ministres ou secrétaires
d'état
il était ce qu'appelle s'accélère des
procédés de record enfin voilà ah oui je
crois qu'il sortait justement de son
poste de secrétaire detat quasiment à ce
moment là et voilà et s'élevait en 2004
je pense aux états de sarkozy est donc
et j'ai en fait j'ai trouvé cette cette
ambiance cette atmosphère finalement
très réjouissante est très exceptionnel
de dire je peux je peux parler à un
public je peux le convaincre je peux le
faire adhérer et donc je fais là je me
suis dit très bien et puis après c'est
plus mais c'est je crois que c'est comme
ça aussi que ça fonctionne hommes
politiques en tout cas je crois que
c'est comme ça beaucoup que ça
fonctionne en france même si on est très
attaché à la démocratie on est toujours
un petit peu en recherche du chef un peu
exceptionnelle qui entraînera la france
vers des destins un peu extraordinaire
et voilà c'est vrai que moi j'ai j'ai
beaucoup soutenu nicolas sarkozy je vous
prie soutenu à mâcon sans parler des
convictions politiques mais par leur
énergie parce qu'il dégageait par le
charisme et ce qui fait que voilà
samassa m'a beaucoup plu là c'est cette
ambiance politique
vous croyez à l'homme providentiel je
crois que ça joue beaucoup et je crois
que ça joue beaucoup dans l'idéal
français de se dire quel est le destin
finalement de notre pays vers quoi ils
temps et malgré tout quand je vois
aujourd'hui et même mais ça ne date pas
de ce quinquennat ça date de deux
quinquennats précédent la responsabilité
qu'ont fait peser sur le président de la
république les attendent qu'on a à
l'égard du président de la république le
fait qu on est presque envie qu'ils
s'immiscent dans chaque petite commune
attend ça
qu'on s'immisce dans chaque petit mise
de chaque pays arbitre h ça m'incite à
penser que c'est quelque chose qui est
assez souhaité oui il dirigeait
oui c'est assez intéressant ce que dit
madame la députée parce qu'en fait on
voit bien en fait qu'il y à des
conceptions différentes aussi de la
république selon que l'on soit de gauche
ou de droite
jeudi le clivage il existe et il
continue d'exister même si on n'est ni
de droite ni de gauche
le clivage ils continuent d'exister
parce que bon on lagos longtemps
historiquement finalement la république
c'est la vente ou la république
parlementaire c'est pas la république de
l'homme providentiel justement et pour
la droite
en effet c'est plutôt la république je
dirais avec un pouvoir fort avec un
exécutif fort
c'est ce que de gaulle finalement
réalisera avec la vème république est là
en effet on est dans cette conception de
l'homme providentiel et de gaulle fait
figure d'homme providentiel comme
d'autres d'ailleurs avant lui il ya eu
des tas il ya eu clemenceau il y en a eu
d'autres qui ont fait dans notre
histoire figure d'homme providentiel
donc il ya bien des conceptions
finalement républicaine qui peuvent être
différentes même si la république je
pense est partagé par l'immense majorité
aujourd'hui les français qu'on soit de
gauche ou de droite et même si pauvre
peut-être nuancer votre propos c'est
vrai que vous avez raison sur les
origines mais après tout la gauche avec
mitterrand a accepté les institutions de
la vème république
mais on peut pas dire que mitterrand
soit comportée très différents modes d
autres candidats à la présidence de la
culture bien sûr mais ça lui était
reproché aussi par une partie de la
gauche qui n'a pas qui n'a pas aimé ces
institutions ah ben oui bien sûr alors
vous vouliez ajouter quelque chose
france sur ce qu on va revenir un peu
justement à l'histoire parce que c'est
intéressant et on va parler notamment de
léon blum
qu'est ce que c'est les leçons de
l'histoire sur la république alors
justement didier fischer vous publié aux
éditions ellipses cette biographie de
léon blum et c'est intéressant d'abord
il faut rappeler que léon blum c'est
d'abord un intellectuel qui vient assez
tard à la politique vous le rappeler
très bien dans ce livre est il se
définissait je crois par trois mots je
suis républicain juifs et socialistes
s'étaient et l'ordre est pas indifférent
l'ordre n'est pas indifférent en effet
les ongles home a été un vrai il l'a
toujours été depuis d'ailleurs que c'est
intéressant de voir ce qui a été son
engagement en effet aux républicains il
est né dans une famille qui le petit
commerçant départ qui a fait fortune
d'une certaine façon un mais qui est
resté finalement dans cette bourgeoisie
commerçante parisienne mais une famille
républicaine et ça c'est important au
départ un bien entendu ensuite son
engagement républicain il va le
conforter dans des rencontres notamment
avec notamment lucien herr qui était le
bibliothécaire de l'école normale et qui
était lui acquis au socialisme et qui va
conduire en effet blum sur le chemin où
les chemins finalement du socialisme
et puis ensuite bloom dans le cadre de
l' affaire dreyfus rencontre jaurès et
là les deux hommes on ne se quitte plus
ensuite
donc il est clair que l'engagement
finalement républicain l'engagement
socialiste aussi de léon blum est lié
dans une grande partie à des rencontres
r blum
enfin jaurès les exactement mais aussi à
des circonstances à des évènements
particuliers celles affaire dreyfus
mais ensuite ça va être l'assassinât de
jaurès ça va être là la première guerre
mondiale est là une certaine manière il
va véritablement s'engager en politique
et quand il devient député vous l'avez
dit il devient finalement député assez
tard c'est-à-dire à 48 ans
il a une carrière de juriste il a aussi
d'une certaine manière une carrière de
critique littéraire à ce moment-là et
théâtral et il s'engage en à l'issue
finalement véritablement à l'issue de la
première guerre mondiale donc en
politique et devient député en 1919
et justement alors mais ça veut
peut-être au port débattre aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est être être
républicain dans les années 30 10 on
voit bien ce que c'est il ya les ligues
fascistes les manifestations du 6
février 34 et c'est qu'on combat le
danger du fascisme en italie du nazisme
en allemagne
donc on voit bien à peu près ce que
c'est être républicain c'était
relativement simple l'impression que
c'est plus simple me semble-t-il sous la
troisième république que ça ne l'est
aujourd'hui de se dire de définir ce
qu'était républicain est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça je ne sais pas si
c'était si c'était plus simple il y
avait effectivement un vrai combat ce
qu'il faut voir quand même à cette
époque c'est je pense qu'il y ait une
césure dans ces années 30 dont vous
parlez celle-ci février 34 avant le 6
février 34 et après 6 février 34 avant
le 6 février 34
être républicain s'est aussi d'une
certaine façon recherché je dirais que
la meilleure république possible le
meilleur gouvernement possible
il ya toute une réflexion sur une
réforme gouvernementale à la suite de la
première guerre mondiale d'ailleurs léon
blum va écrire en 1918 lettres sur la
réforme gouvernementale
et là on voit qu'il ya une recherche
vers en effet je dirais une plus grande
part qui pourrait être attribué en fait
aux pouvoirs exécutifs et bloom est sûre
je dirais set et dans cette voie là en
quelque sorte un au sein du parti
socialiste de l'époque un lay sefyu
il ya aussi un grand débat autour de ce
que l'on va appeler les néo socialistes
qui l'a sont aussi en recherche
autre chose d'une certaine manière ils
veulent dépasser la question ouvrière et
il ya intégré la problématique notamment
des classes moyennes donc on voit bien
qu'ils aient un vrai débat il ya un
débat aussi du côté des radicaux
notamment un ce qu'on appelle les jeunes
turcs ils sont à la recherche d'idées
nouvelles qui prône pour une réforme de
l'état et de l'économie donc il ya la
république n'est pas contestée mais au
contraire d'une certaine façon on essaie
de la perfectionner un durant cette
période
et puis on prêt après il ya le 6 février
34 et là effectivement on est dans ce
combat quasi frontale entre ceux qui
auraient en quelque sorte voulu
renverser la république et les autres
tous et républicains en quelque sorte
qui vont lutter contre le fascisme qui
vont se regrouper d'ailleurs dans le
cadre du comité de vigilance des
intellectuels antifascistes par exemple
et tout cela débouchera vous le savez
sur le front populaire bien en ce moment
une dernière question sur des passes et
un peu le cadre des opprimés justement
sous le front populaire
l'alliance avec les communistes
justement est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est considéré par certains
républicains comme dangereux certains
ont eu le haut ont pu considérer mais je
pense que le problème en fait eu du
front populaire
c'est que ce ne sont pas les socialistes
qui sont en fait à l'origine du front
populaire
mais l'école est communiste en fait le
front populaire in est d'un retournement
de stratégie de l'alliance communistes
en 1934 1 après notamment la prise du
pouvoir par par hitler en allemagne et
c'est en fait torres qui réclame ligne
on l'a au moins de fin mai début juin
1934 qui réclame l'union et les
socialistes léon blum par exemple est
très réticent par rapport à cette union
justement ils pensent mais plutôt un
piège qui comprend mal qu'on puisse en
quelques semaines en quelque sorte
changé totalement de stratégie 1
quelques semaines auparavant les
communistes voulait toujours plus mais
en quelque sorte la volaille socialiste
et en quelques semaines donc vient il
réclame désormais d' unité unité
d'action c'est le fameux discours en
fait de thorez et donc bloom se méfie
véritablement de cela et une certaine
manière n'est pas enclin forcément
accepté la proposition là des
communistes ya une méfiance réciproque
c'est un peu les ennemis enfin les
frères ennemis en fait le parti
socialiste est le parti communiste
à cette époque mais les communistes et
notamment torres va déporter sur sa
droite en quelque sorte léon blum en
prenant langue notamment avec les
radicaux et c'est là que bloom cède et
se lance en effet dans cette dans cet
engagement quelque sorte du front du
front populaire et c'est la fameuse
manifestation du 14 juillet 35 là avec
ce serment sortent du front populaire
alors on va parler on va passer de léon
blum à notre personnage historique
mais pour montrer que au fond balle à la
crainte des attentats la république elle
a toujours existé vous souvenez de ce
cet épisode très très connue d'une
conférence de presse une des premières
conférences de presse de de gaulle quand
il revient ou au pouvoir est-ce que j'ai
jamais adoptée aurait pu leur liberté
publique fondamentale je les ai a
rétabli payé d'une seconde
attendez jamais pourquoi voler ou qu'à
67 ans je connais
une carrière de dictateur
ça c'est la devise et ça débile de votre
inconnu mais qui est d'actualité paris
le bête parce que on entend ce débat
aujourd'hui sur les libertés sur le
matière des libertés et des atteintes
aux libertés
il y avait un article de 2,2 du parisien
récemment france ta liberté est-elle en
danger se dire vous pose la question
s'est il ya en effet le confinement
l'état d'urgence
est-ce que vous pensez que les libertés
sont en danger aujourd'hui on est dans
une période qui est particulière mais je
crois pas pour autant que les libertés
soit en sautant danger elle son
challenge ml sont d'ailleurs pas
forcément de challenge et par ceux
auxquels on pense que j'écoutais ce que
vous disiez sur le 6 février 34
il me rappelle quand même que
aujourd'hui vous voyez on parle de la
liberté de manifester vous pouvez plus
aller manifester sans qu'ils aient des
black blocks qui viennent ou alors
appelons les autres mentions si on le
souhaite mais en tout cas des éléments
qui perturba certes qui est qui viennent
ni provoquer de la violence qui a bien
sûr à la fois s'en prennent aux
institutions je pense aux forces de
l'ordre je pense aux banques etc mais
qui aussi en quelque sorte prive de leur
droit à manifester
ceux qui voudraient faire part de leur
opposition ou de leur soutien à
certaines à certaines des changes crois
que ça s'est assez fondamentale dont on
est peut-être challen papa tient
j'imagine que votre question était
est-ce que politiquement
certains remettent en question nos
libertés je ne crois pas et mai mais on
a des forces
le pouvoir lui même est accusé par
certains de deux d'attenté aux libertés
c'est la deuxième partie de ma réponse
normes et je crois que d'une liga à 10 m
en extérieur ce qui vient d'être changé
et c'est pour ça que nous devons
réaffirmer très fortement notre
attachement à certaines à certaines
libertés et se battre collectivement
pour aller faire les faire respecter
et puis je ne crois pas que malgré la
période que vous avez évoqué le
confinement l'état d'urgence même après
les attentats kelly eu d'atteinte aux
libertés
bien sûr les
exerçons plus totalement dans le même
cadre mais un des éléments fondamentale
et qui revient sur ce que monsieur le
maire concernant par exemple le fait
qu'on était sous un régime parlementaire
c'est que le parlement a continué de
fonctionner toujours pendant ces moments
de très fortes tensions et je crois que
ça c'est justement un élément de la
préservation de nos libertés
c'est à la fois continuer de débattre et
de dire ce que l'on accorde ou non comme
pouvoir à à l'exécutif bien qu'à une
critique
maintenant c'est le conseil de défense
qui pour toutes les décisions et le
parlement n'a même pas à 1 c'est pas
exactement se prononcer sur ces sur sa
décision mais pensez défense ne prend
pas toutes les décisions je ne le crois
pas je crois qu'effectivement c'est
important pour le président d'être dans
plusieurs instances de discuter et
d'échanger mais à la fin des fins et je
crois que c'est un élément qui est
important c'est que vous pourriez avoir
et ce n'est pas le cas mais vous pouvez
très bien avoir un président qui doit le
parlement finalement moi je suis l'homme
providentiel
à quoi ça sert mais in fine et le
gouvernement est obligé de passer devant
le parlement pour faire adopter tout un
certain nombre de dispositions même les
ordonnances qui sont souvent des
dispositifs très critiqués pour autant
qu'elle soit parfaitement
constitutionnel et elles doivent passer
devant le parlement pourrait être
adoptée puis puis pour la ratification
je crois qu'il ya un certain nombre de
garanties et séance à - pardon je suis
très attaché à la vème république c'est
que je pense qu'on a su mettre en place
alors bien sûr elle s'est modernisée
elle a évolué mais un socle est une
structure qui permet justement de
préserver nos libertés fondamentales
stéphane minson je reviens au ce
discours très très connus ressasse
intervention très cosy de de gaulle
c'est vrai que le soupçon d'atteinte aux
libertés il est il est presque constant
dans l'histoire de la vème république il
est constant il est constant surtout de
la part de ou des opposants ou
détracteurs de la vème république
parce qu'il ya en effet et didier
fischer le soulignait à juste titre des
traditions des points de départ qui sont
quand même très différent entre les les
parlementariste et les partisans d'un
d'un pouvoir
incarnez si vous voulez par une par une
autorité ou par un homme c'est ce
qu'explique je pense ce débat mais pour
pour en revenir à aujourd'hui je pense
pas que la république soit menacée par
ce que l'on évoque parfois savoir une
négation ou un amenuisement des droits
et libertés des libertés fondamentales
parce que l'état d'urgence c'est une
légalité c'est malgré tout une légalité
de crise mais c'est une légalité quand
même c'est à dire que on voit très bien
l'argus thèse de notre système à la fois
démocratique de notre système
juridictionnel
n'oublions pas que tous les jours un
certain nombre de mesures
gouvernementales je pense spécifiquement
à des décrets font l'objet dans le cadre
de procédures d'urgence de censure de la
part du conseil d'état ça a été encore
le cas hier à propos des offices
religieux
donc on voit bien que l'état de droit
continuent à fonctionner il fonctionne
en mode dégradé mais heureusement
provisoire mais fonctionne quand même
moi ce qui me semble m aujourd'hui la
république en cause ou du moins en
danger
c'est l'absence ou bien le disons la
distance qu on observe de la part de
nombreux citoyens de nombreux individus
par rapport à l'universalisme de la
république et à la volonté de mettre en
avant
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs je n'ai
pas dans mon viseur telle ou telle
situation particulière mais à mettre en
avant des particularismes qui qui qui
sont en revanche une négation de
l'universalisme républicain
du côté des libertés fondamentales je
pense pas qu'il y a on peut toujours
faire mieux et il faut la république est
un programme mais je pense pas qu'on
soit dans un danger absolu et que
emmanuel macron à l'instar de charles de
gaulle ce serait encore pire parce qu'il
est bien plus jeune
et dans l'idée de le brancher gheriani
deux enjeux et voilà quatre ans que je
vais commencer une carrière j'ai dit là
ce qui pourrait lui mais on va justement
abordé ce que c'est être républicain
aujourd'hui justin florence par cas
deschamps réglé les des avocats sont
assez sensibles justement à ce qui
pourrait être des atteintes aux libertés
ah bah oui puisque nous on est censé
enfin en tant qu'avocat on est des
défenseurs nous sommes des défenseurs
delà de la liberté et c'est vrai qu'il y
a quand même une très grosse inquiétude
par rapport aux attentes notamment en
matière pénale en matière de droit de la
presse sur sur ses libertés et qu'une
tous les jours des avocats en matière
correctionnelle en matière criminelle
vont défendre un certain nombre de
principes quand soit en défense ou qu'on
soit en partie civile peu importe mais
vont défendre c'est ce principe de
liberté ce principe d'égalité et ce
principe de fraternité sur la fraternité
il y avait quand même une décision du
conseil constitutionnel qui a été
extrêmement intéressante et importante
rappelant la fraternité et condamnant
une décision de justice qui avait
condamné une personne qui avait hébergé
et aidé des personnes sans papiers et
donc la défense de cette personne était
de justement de mettre en avant ce
principe de fraternité pour aider et
d'une fraternité d'humanisme voilà même
contre la loi et ils conseil
constitutionnel a appuyé cette défense
en disant que la fraternité peut être
mise en avant à l'encontre justement de
satin principes légaux
c'est ce que mitterrand a appelé dans
une phrase célèbre la force injuste de
la loi
alors justement va aborder maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est être républicain
aujourd'hui on va parler notamment de ce
projet de loi qui va bientôt vous
occupez à l'assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord je reviens quand même à 7
c'est une obsession chez moi mais il me
semble quand même que dans les années de
blum au faux l'immigration était moins
forte elle venait en tout cas beaucoup
plus de l'europe que que d'autres pays
donc l'idée comme ça d'être de croire
dans les mêmes valeurs était plus simple
qu'aujourd'hui est ce que est ce que
c'est votre sentiment aussi où est ce
que je fais un raccourci un peu un peu
bêta c'est sur ce que effectivement
d'une de fait les l'immigration de la
juste de l'élection de l'immigration et
de l'émigration globalement sont plus
fortes et donc il ya beaucoup plus de
brassage des populations avec des gens
mais c'est à la fois une richesse et
c'est aussi un challenge je pense pour
notre société qui viennent de tous
horizons avec des valeurs qui sont qui
sont très différentes et et pour lequel
justement et je crois que cette notion
d'universalisme qui était évoqué tout à
l'heure et très intéressante c'est qu'il
faut et je crois que c'est le rôle de
l'ensemble des institutions essayer de
faire converger tout le monde à la fois
de dire la république c'est un certain
nombre de droits le droit de la libéra
la liberté d'information le droit de
culte par exemple pour reprendre les
thèmes qui nous intéresse
particulièrement en ce moment
mais c'est aussi un certain nombre de
devoirs qu'il faut respecter et parfois
ses devoirs ne sont pas intuitif avec le
pays dont vous êtes
vous êtes d'origine il ya déjà dédé qui
viennent de pays où la religion et
l'état scoffoni non j'ai un exemple très
concret dans ma circonscription
on a des familles qui arrivent des
familles qui sont hébergées
temporairement et dont les enfants sont
scolarisés et qui arrivent de tous
horizons et certains enfants viennent de
pays où par exemple l'égalité homme
femme n'est pas n'est pas un principe il
y a des différences entre les filiations
et les petites filles et bien les
professeurs de l'école publique où ils
sont scolarisés nous faisons c'est un
vrai challenge de faire comprendre à ces
enfants qui sont si petit ils ont à
peine dix ans que un garçon et une fille
sont à égalité difficile d'être plus au
parti socialiste que vous êtes de gauche
par tradition il ya une sorte
d'idéalisation comme ça par la gauche
notamment de la république de
l'enseignement or on s'aperçoit quand
même que ce qu'on appelait l'ascenseur
social ne fonctionne plus que des
inégalités se sont creusées qui a de
moins en moins par exemple de danse
d'enfants d'ouvriers qui qui qui
réussissent normale sup ou polytechnique
est ce qu'on n'a pas un pays d ici au
four 7,7 idées républicaines et et
est-ce qu'elle marche aussi bien qu'on
le voudrait incontestablement il ya il y
à des échecs
l'idée l'idée républicaine c'est
effectivement aussi un idéal c'est pas
seulement là comment dire la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
il faut qu'elle se déplie d'un moment
donné de manière très concrète et
aujourd'hui il y as je pense sur ces
sujets là des interrogations qui
explique en effet qu'une partie
peut-être de nos concitoyens ne se
reconnaissent plus en tous les cas
ou tout au moins considère que ces
valeurs et bien aujourd'hui elles sont
un idéal mais elle ne se traduisent pas
concrètement dans leur vie de tous les
jours et je pense qu'il ya des échecs en
effet en ce qui concerne la république
des inégalités indiscutablement se sont
creusées on parle d'ascenseur social qui
est en panne et on en parle depuis près
d'une vingtaine d'années quand même hein
ce n'est pas récent à ce discours mais
je pense qu'il faut regarder aussi ce
qui se passe autour de nous
regardons ce qui se passe en angleterre
aux états unis même en allemagne
on voit bien que là aussi ces sociétés
sont confrontées aujourd'hui à des
difficultés très importantes qui je
dirais peuvent quelquefois tourné à
l'affrontement et remettre en cause
d'une manière ou d'une autre en tous les
cas l'équilibré social
bon sinon à mon sens je dirais que là la
république aujourd'hui continue malgré
tout d'assurer ses missions je ne pense
pas qu'elle soit aussi défaillante que
certains peuvent le prétendre 1 et je
pense qu'il serait vraiment dangereux de
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain en ce
moment justement vous avez parlé de de
l'angleterre des états unis qui sont des
sociétés plus communautariste qui sont
pas désistés républicaine pour le coup
et bien sûr
finalement alors vous dites c'est ce
gène et rencontrent les mêmes
difficultés que nous est ce que les iris
s'en sortent mieux finalement je suis
pas persuadé qu'il s'en sorte mieux à
l'heure actuelle bien au contraire
j'ai l'impression que notre pays s'en
sort pas si mal
à l'heure actuelle marie sur cette
question pour ces canons et les
gaydailles républicain doit être doit
être rappelé d'ailleurs bon je rappelle
que la loi sur l'eau qu'on appelait la
loi sur le séparatisme pas en notre nom
puisqu'elle phase appelée projet de loi
comportant les principes républicains
en quoi en quoi il faut renforcer les
principes républicains
justement ce que vous disiez c'est à
dire de faire en sorte que les gens
courent d'accueil qui ne sont pas
forcément dans les mêmes valeurs au
départ soit acceptent les valeurs de la
république
c'est un pan est de toute évidence que
je crois pas que ce soit le seul puisque
on a aussi
des enfants des jeunes des adultes qui
ce qui qui sont français et qui
remettent en question très clairement le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
il faut pas oublier que nous avons
effectivement une menace une pression
qui parfois nous vient de l'extérieur
mais nous avons aussi des éléments de
l'ultra gauche qui cherche à remettre en
cause si ce que nous avons vu ce
week-end mais aussi des éléments de
l'ultra droite puisque on sait que
notamment dans les attentats qui ont été
déjoués cette année il y a il ya de ces
de ces personnes moi je crois que
l'intérêt de ce projet de loi sur les
valeurs républicaines c'est que la
société a changé la société a évolué les
cadres dans lesquels elle c'est chacun
exerce ses droits et ses devoirs ont
beaucoup évolué et que l'intérêt de ce
projet de loi c'est notamment peut-être
de rappeler les cadres fondamentaux dans
laquelle les valeurs de la république
s'exerce moi je reviens sur cette
histoire qui est dramatique le droit à
kara caricaturé par exemple c'est
quelque chose auquel on doit être très
attaché j'ai trouvé que le président
quand il a été un petit peu parler
justement de ce droit de caricaturer
dans différentes interviews à
l'international a été très bon le fait
de dire j'entends que certains soit
étiquette mais parce que ce ne sont pas
leurs socle de valeurs et jeu ce n'est
pas le pays dans lequel je souhaiterais
vive mais on peut respecter totalement
cette situation mais je crois qu'il a
été très juste dans le fait de dire nous
avons ce c'est un droit en france
et j'entends faire respecter le droit
dans mon pays et peut-être juste revenir
sur ce que vous avez au pied sur les
garde-fous s'est aussi renforcé le rôle
de ces garde-fous il ya bien sûr les
parlementaires qui interroge le
gouvernement il ya le conseil d'état le
conseil constitutionnel qui sont
d'excellents garde-fous et puis il y a
diverses représentants des institutions
et notamment si on prend l'exemple
toujours du professeur de ce qu'il va
transmettre et de ce qu'il va passer
comme comme valeur je crois que il faut
aussi pouvoir renforcer le rôle et la
parole de ces garde-fous peut-être pas
tant des parlementaires mais le conseil
d'état le conseil constitutionnel dire à
quel point nous y sommes attachés les
enseignants les forces de l'ordre si on
reprend les sujets qui nous intéressait
rappeler aussi à quel point ils sont les
gardiens finalement de nos valeurs et je
crois effectivement que le risque
au delà du de la remise en question de
nous de nos de la république c'est
vraiment un peu la montée des
communautarismes la montée des
particularismes qui est très forte dans
d'autres pays européens voire d'autres
pays d'enhaut qui peut-être à tendance
un petit peu à chercher son chemin en
france et contre lequel nous devons
lutter et je crois que ce texte de loi
permettra aussi de rappeler
l'universalité de la république t'es pas
de mention je te voyais cette phase
qu'on attribue qu'il ait pas de volta
qu'on lui attribue je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vos idées mais je me
battrai pour que vous puissiez les
exprimer
c'est peut-être ça qui est difficile à
aa autant de pour un certain pour
certaines catégories de population
serait que basse et on n'est pas
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord et heroes
bah oui non c'est ça oui c'est puis
c'est passé pas voltaire en fait même et
peu importe là donc dans l'idée de
république ce qui ce qui doit être
aujourd'hui mis en valeur c'est vraiment
cet universalisme et l'universalisme au
fond qu'est ce que c'est parce que pas
plus que la république d'ailleurs or on
a parfois beaucoup de mal à définir
l'universalisme
c'est d'un côté le fait qu' il existe un
commun c'est-à-dire une espèce sous les
2 places commune sur laquelle tout le
monde doit pouvoir se retrouver et la
république c'est partir de l'idée que ce
qui nous rassemble est plus fort que ce
qui nous divise mais ce qui nous divise
ne doit pas être niée simplement ce qui
nous rassemble doit être mis en valeur
il ya ça d'un côté et puis de l'autre
l'universalisme
il doit aussi être portée
enfin en chacun de nous je j'avais je me
remémorais 1 un petit bouquin de régis
debray le philosophe régis debray qui
josé plus c'était un bouquin ses
multiples écrits sur la république
justement il disait si ma mémoire est
bonne il disait le le républicain c'est
un type assez assez étrange
une femme assez étrange elle c'est à
dire c'est un individualiste qui a le
sens du bien public
et puis c'est d'autre part un indocile
qui ne craint pas d'obéir
il ya en chacun de nous en chacun dans
l'esprit de chacun des républicains il
ya sept phare d'universalisme qui est
fait de droit qui est fait de devoir et
je pense que c'est cet équilibre qui est
important il s'agit pas de nier
mais il s'agit simplement de mettre en
valeur ce qui peut nous rassembler et
vous parliez de débats d'acceptation de
l'opinion contraire ça évidemment c'est
consubstantiel à la république
mais la république est la seule à deux à
la fois de fort et d' extrêmement
fragile c'est que la république c'est un
système qui avait ses propres fragilités
et qui invite à discuter à améliorer à
débattre de ses fragilités
à l'opposé de bien d'autres systèmes
politiques
à l'opposé de bien d'autres systèmes de
valeurs et c'est ça qui fait à la fois
la force et la fragilité de la
république
vous avez raison de se lier au fola la
république c'est quelque chose de
complexe même à même la terre d d d d d
individus il ya un mot qu'on n'a pas
prononcé
marie lebey que c'est celui-là is it et
qui est consubstantielle à la république
alors la république qui est la laïcité
ça va évidemment de pair est-ce qu'il
faut renforcer justement cette laïcité
ce qu'il faut revenir sur la loi de 1905
ou est ce qu'elle peut s'appliquer telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui la situation
situation actuelle en préparation de
cette loi un débat et un séminaire très
intéressant au sein du groupe justement
vise
à auditionner plusieurs personnalités on
a eu ce week-end et déjà peut-être
rappeler que quand même la laïcité c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est assez
français il ya assez peu de pays dans le
monde qui sont qui sont pour lequel
l'état est laïque et je crois que c'est
quelque chose dont on doit être être
fier moi j'ai beaucoup réfléchi cas est
ce qu'on peut faire bien sûr en france
mais il ya aussi la perception de ce
qu'est la laïcité à l'international est
en fait parfois sept valeurs auxquelles
je suis moi même très attaché elle a un
peu tendance à à renvoyer peut-être a
désigné la france comme un ennemi de
ceux qui seraient contre la laïcité et
qui voudraient la challenge et je crois
que au delà de ce texte il y aura un
vrai travail a engagé peut-être pour
aller expliquer notamment à travers nos
réseaux diplomatiques dans mon ski est
là est ce que ce qu'est la laïcité est
ce qu'est ce concept
ce concept qui est pas évident pour un
certain nombre de d'abord à la laïcité
c'est pas la même chose forcément à
l'école que quand on est adulte enfin
série il ya des grandes des différences
qui sont en effet complexe vous ai
beaucoup apprécié la là dedans à
l'occasion de ce séminaire la phrase
d'un des intervenants qui justement
indiqué la laïcité c'est ce qui permet
de devenir un individu est pas une
identité et je crois que c'est assez
fort parce que finalement c'est le fait
de dire vous pouvez être d'origine afin
de pratiques musulmanes chrétiennes
juive peu importe vous avez le droit de
choisir que vous êtes croyant que vous
n'êtes pas croyant vous avez le droit de
choisir la façon dont vous souhaitez
pratiquer votre froid mais mais à titre
personnel je crois aussi qu'il faut
réaffirmer le rôle de l'alizé mais aussi
le fait de dire que la religion relève
de la sphère privée et qu'elle doit
s'exercer librement dans la sphère
privée mais que dans la sphère publique
c'est on doit à adhérer à ce principe de
laïcité c'est à dire le respect d'une
forme de neutralité collective alors
pour conclure parce qu'il te reste plus
beaucoup de temps dans son discours des
mureaux le président de la république a
dit aussi il faut rendre la réplique
plus attirante en quoi elles pourraient
être plus attirante
parce que sur ce que vous disiez là sur
la laïcité et je pense qu'il faut être
la laïcité c'est pas quelque chose qui
exclut la laïcité c'est aussi quelque
chose qui respecte l'ensemble de
croyance et qui est plutôt inclusive
humaniste et voilà ce serait quand même
bien de se poser des questions sur la
verse et puis quand on voit
effectivement le l'immigration qui vient
en france et qui vient de toutes sortes
de pays
il va falloir se poser des questions sur
la façon dont on vit ensemble même si on
a effectivement peut-être des valeurs
qui sont pas forcément les mêmes
notamment sur la religion mais on a tous
à mon sens même des personnes qui
viennent ici elles viennent ici pas pour
rien n'y a pas que de l'immigration
économique qui a aussi bien joué nous à
l'arrivée un choix et je pense que tout
le monde est bien d'accord sur liberté
égalité fraternité alors égalité ça va
dépendre un peu aussi des convictions
religieuses mais au moins liberté
fraternité ce sont des mots qui sort des
valeurs fortes et qui doivent s'adapter
parce que tout le monde doit y adhérer
ses fans en sont un public plus
attirante serait quoi enfin patrice moi
je suis très mal placé parce que je suis
je suis républicain pur jus mois la
réparer c'est un truc génial c'est un
pro un projet magnifique c'est un
programme extraordinaire liberté égalité
fraternité laïcité
moi je je je me retrouve partout là
dedans donc est ce qu'on voulait c'est
aussi c'est aussi le message sans sens
endoctrinés évidemment mais c'est le
message que je fais passer aussi devant
les étudiants
je les invite à y réfléchir librement se
positionner
c'est ça au fond est républicain c'est
dire vous avez un système de valeurs qui
est à votre disposition vous pouvez les
façonner les discuter les mettre en
doute et c'est à vous de vous
positionner librement donc c'est un
projet absolument absolument génial et
est absolument moderne des défis sert
aux quelques secondes s'il y avait une
leçon à retenir de léon blum
ça serait laquelle les leçons de léon
blum
c'est ça en prend quelques secondes
c'est un petit peu difficile mais bon
savoir que bloom finalement au péril de
sa vie a défendu la république
je pense par exemple aux réunions il
n'était pas évident en effet de deux
sauts de s'opposer de cette façon-là au
régime de vichy
marie le bec pour conclu alors justement
on est dans une période troublée
difficile il ya cette crise sanitaire et
le terrorisme
il ya des difficultés économiques
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'il nous
ferait espérer aujourd'hui n'ont pu se
réfugier à notre question dans les
autres intervenants paraît j'ai pas
vraiment je ne suis pas d'élément de
réponse par contre ce sur quoi s'est
interrogé comment est ce qu'on ramène
les français dans le dans le débat
républicain et comment est ce qu'on les
fait participer à la vie démocratique et
politique de notre pays je crois que si
on arrive à me remettre cette mécanique
on peut aussi au rang de la république
plus attractive merci beaucoup
et après que des français dans la
république et c'est peut-être l'un des
uns des sujets je crois qu'il faudrait
aborder
moi je pense aux droits de vote
notamment des résidents non européens
ça peut être un sujet que l'on pourrait
discuter qui est un vieux sujet qui
revient comme ça comme le cerveau de la
mer que personne ne prend jamais à son
compte
merci mon goût merci beaucoup marie le
bec merci beaucoup france par fred et
choqué merci beaucoup stéphane manceau
merci beaucoup didier fischer je
rappelle votre livre léon blum 7 aux
éditions ellipses
merci à tous les quatre mairies à
bientôt pour un nouveau prof
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]